voilà jean paul rouve est devenu un vrai
pro donc on va vers une interview promo
de pro jean paul rouve est ce qu'on peut
dire que le film de bernard rapp c'est
d'abord une rencontre est quelque part
un aboutissement pro un problème c'est
une rencontre c'est une rencontre avec
un personnage j'ai envie de dire puis un
aboutissement c'est dix ans de travail
acharné de de vache enragée pour arriver
à ça si c'est bien aux notes bernard
rapp le réalisateur ce qui vous
intéressait c'était de rencontrer
bernard rapp
l'homme non j'imagine oui oui bah oui
bernard ap l'homme au sahara était
bernard ap la femme j'aurais pris fils
le prince vous pensez qu'il a su voir en
vous au delà de l'image que vous avez
oui oui je pense que ça va dit joe
jean-paul wipro jouit je pense que ce
que bernard a su voir en moi il a su
voir en moi le comique mais qui est a su
retirer son son nez rouge de clown c'est
vrai qu'elle fait mais vous a remarqué
dans quelle fille nîmes a remarqué
bernard à bernard en robin des bois
est-ce que vous avez su voir si tu ton
film de merde est le plus cité pour vous
évidemment il n'y a pas de secret avec
du travail
je suis et je dirais je suis un artisan
ouais un artisan du rêve
ouais c'est bien l'artisan du réseau
s'est bien trouvé ses classes avant tout
ce film restera une expérience
passionnante j'imagine avec une équipe
magnifique et quelque part une famille
d'une sorte bien sûr fait de la grande
famille du cinéma vous à grande famille
du cinéma évidemment pensé que ce film
de la maturité pour vous jean paul je
pense que c'est le film de la maturité
de la thune parce que j'ai pris grave
jean-paul si vous arrêtez de jouer un
jour vous mourrez ah oui moi je crois
que je suis comédien au fond de l'âme
c'est ma vie je suis né pour ça c'est
bon je mourrai avec sa hache sur scène à
je mourrai sur six mois bravo molière
jean mathis si tu nous regardes
marina foïs sortie le 15 juin